[Music]
moving on our main story tonight
concerns homelessness and i know that we
are by no means the first show to cover
this subject many have tried and perhaps
not more memorably than the criminally
cancelled tyra bank show
i wanted to understand what their lives
are really like and walk a day in their
shoes
no makeup no lights nothing but me
i stopped at two kids in the street
playing ball
hi
my name is tyra
hi what's your name
franklin i mean there is so much going
on there but i want to focus on
franklin's face because that is the face
of a kid who's definitely figured out
the secret identity of the woman who had
a camera crew looked like tyra banks and
introduced herself saying hi my name is
tyrone
but despite tyra's best efforts
homelessness is still a huge problem in
this country for the fourth consecutive
year it increased nationwide with the
most recent count suggesting there are
over 580 000 people experiencing
homelessness in america but the truth is
it is likely way more than that because
that annual count only includes people
that surveyors could find on the streets
or in shelters on a single night last
year a system that misses countless
people and not just that experts project
the pandemic recession could cause
chronic homelessness to increase 49
over the next four years and with this
rise in homelessness has come a
corresponding rise in the rhetoric
around it exemplified by segments like
this
we came out just have some time it's a
great time everybody's safe it's america
it's my home
this used to be one of the crown jewels
of austin but as you can see another
tent city the guy's walking around with
a machete threatening people it started
with box cutters as a weapon now we
sadly we joke that we're the machete
capital of texas
okay hold on i i'm not saying that
someone walking around with a machete
isn't scary but you are making an
outlier seem like the norm there and
you've gone out of your way to make it
scarier with visual effects and you can
make anything frightening that way here
i'll show you here is a bit of fun just
shaquille o'neal dancing with the
jabberwockies oh god oh no no it's
terrifying leave him alone jabberwockies
leave shaq alone run shaq just run
and look
i know it is easy to criticize fox news
for being alarmist alarmism is their
whole thing that and airing ads for
pills that make your dick go bongo but
the truth is even some residents of
austin famously a blue dot in a red
state have said it's been a struggle to
reconcile their feelings about their
homeless neighbors do you think if you
had seen this issue happening in another
city and it wasn't happening in your
neighborhood you would feel differently
once you're in the middle of it you
change your mind of how you approach the
situation but as your safety declines so
does your compassion
every every time i have to pick up human
my liberalness just got lowered one
but one more notch
wow that is very honest every time i
have to pick up human my liberalism
gets lowered is quite the sentence
although i'm surprised it was heard in
this context and not in a leaked
recording from an amy klobuchar staff
meeting and look again i am not saying
that that is a nice situation to be
presented with but far too often stories
focusing on homelessness are presented
solely through the lens of how it
affects those with homes when in reality
it is obviously the people without them
who need the real help and the
demonization of the homeless community
in austin may well have contributed to
incidents like this
we had so many people
throw glass bottles
from their cars
at our tents
and said we all want trash y'all need
to get a job y'all need to
get housing y'all don't need to be out
on the streets
or some would yell out go home it's like
this is technically our home
right and that is obviously horrible
although i will say no one screaming out
of a car window has ever said anything
worthwhile it's like giving a eulogy
through flash mob the method of delivery
alone is just immediately disqualifying
the story of homelessness in this
country is grounded in a failure of
perception compounded by failures of
policy so tonight let's look at the way
homelessness is talked about how the
problem is currently being made worse
and what could actually help and like so
many things the modern version of this
issue was turbocharged by ronald reagan
who came to power at a time when
homelessness was increasing and made the
problem far worse by cutting programs
for the poor and slashing housing
subsidies by 75 percent making it pretty
galling that reagan regularly made
arguments like this
one problem
that we've had even in the best of times
and that is the people who are sleeping
on the greats the homeless who are
homeless you might say by choice
uh i'm sorry homeless by choice look
there were lots of things from 1984 that
we could have used an undo button for
long dok dong most of temple of doom
this extremely unfortunate jello ad but
reagan's quarter asked thoughts on
homelessness are near the top of that
list and that notion that homelessness
isn't related to economic policies but
simply reflects the problems of the
individuals experiencing it still
informs the way it's discussed today
here is dr drew of all people talking to
seth green of all people and pushing
back on the notion of the homeless
crisis in la might have anything to do
with a shortage of affordable housing
this isn't a housing problem it's not no
no that's a hoax that's a hoax being
perpetrated by the government here
locally that there's a job to stop that
there isn't because it seems that of
course we have housing expense issues
but we we just absorbed a million
illegal uh undocumented immigrants
without a home without a country without
a job without a penny we absorbed them
they found a place to live
it's a hoax so it's a mental health
crisis and addiction crisis full-on
oh okay then i certainly don't see why
we wouldn't innately trust dr drew
confidently mouth-splooging
theories to dr evil son but
a few notes on what he said there set
aside the nonsense that undocumented
immigrants don't experience homelessness
because experts will tell you that they
very much do they're just less likely to
avail themselves of services because of
the whole undocumented thing instead
let's address the notion that all of
this is down to mental health and
addiction because yes many who are
homeless do struggle with both those
things and those people are often the
most visible but by no means all of them
also in many cases those struggles can
be the result of being homeless and not
the cause of it the truth is there are
many reasons someone might find
themselves without housing medical debt
job loss fleeing domestic violence being
kicked out of their homes because their
parents don't approve their sexuality or
being recently released from prison or
just the overriding fact that housing
costs are rising much faster than wages
currently 70 percent of all extremely
low income families are spending more
than half their income on rent and only
37 affordable and available homes exist
for every hundred extremely low income
renter households and that is a
startlingly low number especially
considering just how much this country
loves watching tv shows about homes
little homes humungo homes homes for
ghosts and homes remodeled by weirdo
twins who definitely shower together to
name just a few of them the point here
is it doesn't take much for people to
suddenly find themselves without stable
housing as this woman found out
two years ago priscilla had a full-time
job at a health clinic for the homeless
her husband ryan stayed home to care for
their two sons
the youngest had severe autism
they lived on a tight budget and then
their landlord raised the rent 150
dollars
that's a lot of money for a lot of
people that live paycheck by paycheck
and we live like that
the family was evicted and in a place
they never imagined homeless themselves
living in their car i work at a homeless
clinic and i'm homeless how the heck
does that happen to me
yeah that is an awful situation to be in
you never want to find yourself suddenly
saying how did this happen to me with
the sole exception of being if you are
knee-deep in stanley tucci sheets and
even then why question it you're
swimming in touch peppermint this is
going to be a delight
so despite reagan's confidence there can
be not much choice in the matter after
all as for those outward signs of
homelessness that raise such alarm they
are typically the result of public
policy choices that we have made
remember that woman complaining about
human that is actually a common
thread in coverage of the homeless in la
you can find multiple stories about
human feces near homeless encampments
but it's worth knowing there is a reason
for that
most of the city's hundreds of
encampments are nowhere near a public
toilet
in fact la has only 16 mobile toilet
stations for its 36 thousand homeless
people to make matters worse with no
funding for round-the-clock security the
city hauls away these toilets at night
leaving the homeless no choice but to go
on the streets what the to all of
that from the amount of public toilet
stations available being less than the
amount of bond movies to shuffling those
very minimal toilets away like they're
going to turn into a pumpkin at midnight
and while that clip is from just before
the pandemic which prompted city
officials to increase toilet stations
there are still currently only 55
accessible 24 7. so the next time you
complain about human in the street
maybe think about what it would be like
if someone padlocks your bathroom every
night you too will suddenly be getting
really creative really fast
and it seems the impulse behind many
local policies surrounding unhoused
people isn't so much to help them as to
punish them for their existence and keep
them out of sight you're probably
familiar with hostile architecture
designed to prevent homeless people from
sitting and lying on certain properties
it's why you'll sometimes see spikes
under bridges like this or benches with
dividers to prevent anyone lying down
and one city went even beyond
architecture debate raging over a
florida city playing children's music at
a park pavilion at night to keep
homeless people away people say the
music rotates between baby shark
and this song
it's raining
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true they pumped the song raining
tacos of people when they were just
trying to sleep which is completely
inhumane nobody deserves that also and i
know this isn't the key point that song
doesn't deserve it either because it is
a certified banger take a listen
[Music]
stop stop stop stop stop i would love to
play you more but the problem is this
show would then get too fun and i'd
spend the rest of the show dancing in
the isles with you and ellen would
literally kill me
but it but it is not just spikes and
songs more and more city ordinances have
been put into place criminalizing
behaviors associated with being homeless
over the course of 13 years city-wide
bans on camping have increased by 92
percent on sitting or lying by 78
on loitering and panhandling by 103
and on living in vehicles by 213
so when you hear fear-mongering about
rising crime among the homeless it's
worth asking yourself if those crimes
were actually crimes or just someone sat
down
take kenneth schultz a 71 year old
homeless man who told reporters
sometimes i just get exhausted and boom
sit down that's it you're trespassing in
the nine years he's been homeless he's
been charged with trespassing 96 times
and has spent one of every three nights
in jail and think about what that means
it means he spent three of the last nine
years behind bars in what way is that
man being helped you cannot arrest
someone out of homelessness in the same
way they can't sing someone out of
bankruptcy one thing doesn't remotely
lead to the other and he's just going to
end up making things worse even if
you're singing this
[Music]
no no turn it off i am warning you ellen
is sharpening her knives as we speak
she'll do it it won't be the first time
and criminalizing homelessness exposes
already vulnerable populations to
unnecessary interactions with the police
unhoused people of color are more likely
to be cited searched and have property
taken than white people experiencing
homelessness and those with multiple
marginalized identities like lgbtq plus
people of color are even more vulnerable
to these laws and if you're thinking
well hold on why don't homeless people
just go to shelters there can be a lot
of problems with that some cities simply
don't have enough beds for everyone in
oakland for example in 2019 there were
457 beds available for more than 4 000
unhoused people meaning they couldn't
provide everyone with a bed even if they
really wonkered the situation and if i
may i'd actually like to pause at this
point for just a quick tangent so put um
40 seconds on the clock please um
regarding this i don't mind charlie's
grandparents sleeping in one bed
everyone always asks but what about when
they have to do they
separately or all do it together to
which i say i don't care and i hope so
they're not related by blood they're
related by their children's marriage
it's not their fault they have to share
one rickety bed grandpa george is going
to want to make love to grandma georgina
they've shared a life together and
grandpa joe is obviously going to want
to get it in grandma josephine that's
the mother of his children but at a
certain point if you don't invite the
couple sleeping in the same bed to join
in it is just real so the next time you
talk about charlie bucket's elder
sexual proclivities ask yourself this
are they the problem or were you just
raising the pure technical society that
shames any sexual deviation from the
quote unquote norm
oh that's my time that's my time
i said my peace
back to the sad stuff the point is some
cities don't have enough shelter beds
and even in those that have many like
here in new york they are not always an
option for everyone some might not want
to split up their family or part with
their pets or simply wary of bringing
their only possessions around a room
full of strangers but also the key
problem with saying why don't people
just go to shelters is that shelters are
only a stop gap solution because you
don't live in a shelter you just sleep
in one as this woman points out
it's
very very rough i would rather stay on
the streets and this is why i understand
when i see a lot of homeless people
while they're on the streets
shelter degrades you i work
part-time i went from a full-time job to
a part-time job being in the shelter
because there's just too much going on i
have to be in at eight o'clock
every night if i'm not in at eight
o'clock i lose that bed you wake up at
five o'clock you have to be out of there
at 7 o'clock regardless
yeah an 8 p.m curfew and a 7 a.m kick
out the door so if pulling yourself up
by your bootstraps involves working
nights i'm sorry you're out of luck
and if you're thinking no john surely a
shelter eventually helps people get back
on their feet everything worthwhile in
life takes time i read that on a pillow
once well think again because just look
what happened when the person who filmed
that woman caught up with her almost
eight years later you talked about going
in and out of the shelter system
and that's still happening and that
still happened
they place you
they let you go they move you they let
you go
they get your money from the government
they let you go and you're still
misplaced yeah the shelter system has
done nothing to change her circumstance
and i will be the first to admit here
it's impossible for me to understand
just how hard that cycle is i've been
lucky enough to have always lived in a
department or a house or most recently
an infinite white void run by an abusive
landlord that was hard in its own way
but it was nothing compared to a
potentially life or death game of
musical beds so if all we've mentioned
so far tonight poking homeless people
with spikes blasting with music and
locking them up doesn't solve this
problem what does well this housing
advocate has a bold new idea
the solution is simple this is what the
solution is it's the only thing that is
homelessness is this right here house
keys exactly house keys in other words
give the homeless homes it's the
solution you've probably been shouting
at your tv for the past 15 minutes or
let's be honest shouting at your laptop
or if we're being really honest shouting
at your phone during your monday morning
and
if you are annoyed that i wasted your
time taking the scenic route here let me
make it up to you with another excellent
clip from the tyra bank show
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there is some context for that but the
truth is it honestly wouldn't make it
make much more sense
now some will say sure giving the
homeless homes is an obvious solution
but before that they need to be sober
and have a job but it's just not that
simple set aside that dealing with
sobriety or your mental health issues is
hard enough when you are not living on
the streets getting a job is often if
not contingent on at least aided by
having an address that is why advocates
endorse an approach called housing first
it prioritizes helping people get a
place to live but also offer support
like mental health and addiction
services we've actually tried a version
of this with homeless veterans before
and it had some real success
the first step of this new model is a
permanent house funded mostly at
government expense with services then
added around the resident it's called
permanent supportive housing and that's
what lendl c found himself in
c lives in this complex that houses only
formerly homeless veterans while there
is no firm program that he has to follow
he has access to support services
including on-site case managers mental
health counseling substance abuse
treatment and even a community garden it
feel good
sometimes i walk around apartment no no
tv or nothing on and just singing for no
reason at all and then i catch myself
done and i started laughing i said you
must be going crazy now but i'm just
happy a good question it feels good
that is a very nice thing to see it's
like two babies hugging or four
grandparents absolutely railing each
other it's something that just fills you
with hope
and thanks to this housing first
strategy the number of homeless veterans
dropped from 74 000 in 2010 to 38 000 in
2018 and near 50 reduction and
supportive housing is just one version
of what this can look like for those
recently made homeless rapid re-housing
provides short-term rental assistance
and services to help people get back on
their feet quickly and look housing
first programs clearly require
significant resources and funding but it
is not like our current approach is
cheap one study in florida that tracked
a decade's worth of spending on just 107
chronically homeless people found that
just between money spent on
incarceration and emergency medical
treatment their communities and local
governments have spent an average of
just over thirty one thousand dollars
per person per year when the estimated
cost of providing with permanent
supportive housing would have only been
around ten thousand dollars per year so
if your argument against housing for the
homeless was purely monetary
congratulations your concerns have been
answered also a pre-congratulation for
being visited by three ghosts this
upcoming christmas eve
but funding is not the only issue here a
huge obstacle in implementing these
sorts of programs is opposition from
local residents it is the nimby problem
not in my backyard and it happens
absolutely everywhere take claremont
california where new developments
offering affordable housing including
those geared to the homeless were
proposed only to encounter fierce
community pushback like this
you don't need to put it in our backyard
it's not fair but what they're doing is
pass crazy well it's just going to go
downhill if you bring all that in all
their riffraff i don't need it it's just
not the right place
i agree that they need help i agree that
they need to find a location but
claremont's not the location to be had
how is that going to impact crime how is
that going to impact
the businesses out here if they're low
income are they going to be spending
money at the sushi place or you know or
not oh no not the sushi place
i didn't realize a prerequisite for
housing was a willingness to spend
friday nights deep throating the geary
as for that guy saying i agree they need
to find a location just not here
where then because you do get just
because someone leaves your site doesn't
mean they stop existing right it's a
concept that we all learn pretty early
on after about eight months of
absolutely terrifying games of
peek-a-boo
and claremont is by no means an isolated
example in north texas local residents
mobilized against a proposed affordable
housing project which had units set
aside for residents using housing choice
or section 8 vouchers basically rental
subsidies for low-income or homeless
individuals and here is how one opponent
of the project explained herself
the lifestyle i feel like that is goes
with section 8 is usually working um
single maybe single moms or people who
are struggling to keep their heads above
water and it's not i feel so bad saying
that but it's not
um it's just not people who are i guess
of the same
class as us which sounds bad but i don't
mean that in a bad way do you think that
you maybe
are stereotyping the folks oh i totally
am 100 it's not it works both ways i
i'm definitely not a racist and i'm not
bigot but um i
i think i hold a little bit of a stigma
against people who
are different
okay some
quick corrections there you don't feel
that bad saying it the things you're
saying are things racists and bigots say
and saying i'm not a racist or a bigot
but also saying you have a stigma
against people who are different isn't
necessarily splitting hairs but it's
definitely segregating them
while that woman lives in a conservative
area of texas plenty of the places
you've seen tonight and plenty of the
places where these sentiments run
deepest are deep blue liberal cities the
truth is some of you watching this right
now may share some of those views and if
you do i implore you to take in every
word of this formerly unhoused mother
kiana k scott who wrote a letter to the
nimbys in her hometown you wear your
bias like a badge of honor when you see
my history you judge me for having
children for needing assistance you hate
me for wanting the stability you take
for granted and why
because you didn't like looking the
other way when you saw me on the street
or is it simply because i make you
uncomfortable and your discomfort is
enough to disqualify a person from the
american dream exactly she's absolutely
right it is not the house comfort that
needs to be prioritized right now so if
you're wondering why homelessness
continues to get worse in this country
one reason is that there are a lot of
people even liberals who believe that
homelessness is a personal failing
poverty can be avoided and their own
good fortune makes them not only better
than the unhoused but more worthy of
comfort it is basically reagan's
attitude from a whole foods crowd and i
do not want to oversimplify the
logistics involved here it will take a
massive commitment in infrastructure
funding and resources but the very first
step here is a collective change of
perceptions basically we need to stop
being dicks and assuming that the
unhoused are a collection of drug
addicts criminals who've chosen this
life for themselves instead of people
suffering the inevitable consequences of
gutted social programs and a nationwide
divestment from affordable housing i
really hope that is one of the two key
things that sticks in your head from
tonight's show the other of course
being this
that's our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night
[Music]
you